une parcelle de forêt publique arrosée
au glyphosate selon caroline de bordeaux
si un arrosage aux frais des
contribuables et aux profits de
l'industrie qui récolte le bois la
présidente du mouvement stop the new
brunswick fait partie des invités du
comité législatif qui doit mener à des
recommandations quant à l'utilisation
d'herbicides
elle s'inquiète de la conservation de
l'habitat de certaines espèces règlement
on a fait aussi au programme d'accepter
de vie sociale en ce qu'ils vont ne
sonne pas juste l'utiliser son
territoire
mais en général jamais la population néo
brunswickoise ne s'est autant mobilisés
dans une pétition un nombre record de
signatures 35000 a été recueillie pour
que ça s utilisation du glyphosate nous
les politiciens nous avons raté notre
coup lens le ministre conservateur des
ressources naturelles au sujet de la
foresterie mike rolen siège au comité de
l'assemblée législative
il considère que le gouvernement a trop
longtemps été à la merci de l'industrie
et qu'il a oublié le volet
environnemental au fil des ans
comme ministre il ne cache pas son
opinion sur le glyphosate mairie il est
sûr cependant qu'il sera impartial en
tant que membre du comité chargé de
formuler des recommandations à son
cabinet une double fonction l'escala
inaugurera aussi perplexe tous les
partis de l'opposition à fredericton se
sont prononcés contre l'épandage de
glyphosate sur les terres publiques
elle aurait préféré un processus plus
indépendants comme celui du bas au
québec
le bureau d'audiences publiques sur
l'environnement le québec est la seule
province canadienne ayant interdit
l'utilisation du glyphosate en forêt se
trouve entre provence et comment se
repérer au cas où le glyphosate serait
un vrai trou au casque ou le silence te
montrent un problème avec les façades
alors il commençait investing et les
entraîneurs aussi
l'industrie forestière est un des
secteurs économiques les plus importants
du nouveau brunswick
elle représente 1 milliard 700 millions
du produit intérieur brut soit 4 et demi
pour cent et fait travailler vingt mille
personnes
je suis peut être fou dit le ministre
mais il croit que maintenir l' industrie
prospère et conserver la biodiversité de
la forêt publique est possible et si
monde montambault radio-canada springer